a 26 year old driver who mowed down and
killed a knifeman in west london has
been released today without charge leon
mccaskey died after being hit by the
vehicle in maida vale in london the
collision happened moments after he
stabbed his ex-partner to death in the
street our crime correspondent martin
brunt joins me now and martin this uh
case made the headlines because the
driver was arrested and thousands of
people signed a petition for his release
saying he was a hero not a villain in
this
indeed i mean even
the woman's family hailed the driver
as a hero
and already this
decision by the metropolitan police has
been widely
applauded on twitter lots of positive
responses to it
the metropolitan police
has spent what eight days looking at the
circumstances
and it has said in a statement that um
that they had renewed the legal position
regarding self-defense that was the key
issue
that the driver
who's been identified only as abraham
that's what he'd been telling people
through his lawyer that he had simply
used his car to intervene because it was
it was a terrible violent
affair and this man
um leon mccaskirt was stabbing his
ex-wife um in front of witnesses who had
tried to intervene he'd threatened them
and abraham got back in his car and used
that to drive at uh the
knife man and try to stop it now in the
end uh he ended up killing uh mr
mccasker
and the woman had already died from her
stab wounds but the police have said um
in some
way in their defense it is vitally
important that when a person dies
there's a thorough
investigation into all of the
circumstances and this has taken place
such decisions must be thoroughly
examined and while this process takes
time this has been a priority uh for the
team of investigators so i think that's
a decision that by the met that will be
widely applauded um at a time when i
seem to spend most of my time bashing up
the metropolitan police for one reason
or another
the man abraham
now becomes a key witness in this case
and has been released with no further
action but until today had the
possibility of a murder charge hanging
over him